his unique drawings can be seen all
across las vegas jorge benticott's work
is really one of a kind and as we
continue to celebrate hispanic heritage
month check out how this local artist
drops touch of latin culture in each
piece he creates
[Music]
every piece is joy
this is the most important thing for me
[Music]
a unique style of artwork on display on
this alley in the arts district of las
vegas all my artwork is
a playful stuff jorge bentacort is a
mexican native but has called las vegas
home for the past 30 years his work is
as colorful and vibrant as his
personality this is the inspiration for
me and not just
my childhood by itself but also the kid
i have in meals because i really like to
have fun and the things i do and really
like to bring a joy to the
to the people the 57 year old has
collaborated on multiple popular
children's books including dreamy girls
field of wishes and granny mcfannie
which won mom's choice award among other
recognitions all all the artists we are
all the first thing we are looking for
is style we really need to have
something unique something you know it
can
make us a difference that unique touch
is on a long list of art exhibits in las
vegas but benicort says his next project
will spread beyond the exhibition hall
this is the amp
utility box i was selected by the city
to to put my artwork there so yeah i'm
very happy a talented artist with a big
heart who hopes to bring joy to others
through his work christian caceres 8
news now